My back is sweating from drinking hot tea. My front is sweating. I have sweats on. I'm sweating. Showing your microphone is on. Oh, sorry. Showing your microphone is on. Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Why do you think they call it sweats? You think they call it sweats because you're supposed to sweat in those clothes? Yeah, probably. But what do they not invent shorts? No, but do they look up in the center of a genius sandwich? Fuck it out. But why would you, if you're gonna make sweats, why did they not have shorts back then?
No, I know. They need like a pull-away sweats. So they could just... They've got sweats from sweats to shorts, like in a second. Yeah, you ever a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, Smart. Lies. Smart. Blast. Hey, good morning. Is this better for everybody? 9.30 in the morning? Hi, is it good morning better now? How about it?
We're going to have a little less complain. Who's complaining? No, we had a few late night. Well, one of them you called a late night. It was a 4 p.m. Yeah, I was already in my pajamas. Oh, well, that had a few late night. Well, one of them you called a late night, it was a four p.m. I was already in my pajamas. Oh, well, that's pretty late. I know.
That's a late night, unless you're in Hawaii. I know. You know, and it's lunch. Right now, it's lunch in New York City. It's lunch in New York City. But it's breakfast here in LA. Yeah. It is. Look, I got my tea. Morning, you guys.
What did you guys have for breakfast this morning? Nothing yet. Really? I actually had a piece of toast with some natural peanut butter and a couple slices of banana on top. Sounds fun. What was it feeling great this morning? Oh, really? What happened? I don't know. What's, what's, what's, is it tummy? Yeah, a little tummy and, um, What's, what's, what's, what's, is it tummy? Is it bad? Little tummy and, and baby woke up in the night, when he's not a baby anymore, but a little throw up in the middle of the night.
Oh my God, Ricky threw it last night. Really? Yeah. Maybe Danny got into your trash, right? Ricky. Um, the, I don't, I don't eat till noon. Is that right? Yeah.
It's too much. It's fucking watch out. I don't, I don't eat till noon. Is that right? Yeah. It's been a minute. Then it's fucking watch out. Everything real trouble. Do you really do it? You do that like that fasting thing? Is that what time the timer on the locks goes off on the cabinet? The cabinet. That's what Scottie said all the timers for.
Yeah, you can hear the tick tick. Are you doing a, let's not eat for... Well, I'll just think. Yeah, sure. I'm just never, ever, have never been hungry ever in my whole life in the morning. I just, the first time I eat it. But you are right about to watch out.
I'll eat everything. And then you'll go late. Will you eat late? No, and then I'll have a really little dinner. That's it. Well, let's check the tape on that. Will, can we run the tape on that? Yeah, I mean, I just can say,
that's a little heavy on the cheese, like, whatever. No, I eat just a little, but I do, I eat little portions so I can eat big desserts. Right, yeah. You saved the room for the dessert. Yeah, for sure. Yeah.
I made a mistake. The yesterday, Will FaceTime me, I was in the middle of therapy, and I was like, yeah, I'll pick it up. And she's like, oh, excuse me. And I was like, yeah. And therapist is like, oh, what are you doing? And he says, and the first thing he says is, hey, man, I go, hey, he goes, I go, I'm in therapy.
And I showed a picture, I turned the camera around to show him my therapist is like, hello. And he goes, oh, my therapist just died. I was like, really? And he said, he collapse from the weight of my secrets. That was pretty funny. Do you often take calls during therapy? No, but my phone just happened to be like the flap open.
You know, you call it my purse. Oh, right. And yeah, and I saw that it was a phone book. My phone book. Huh. Huh. Gosh, we get into it. This is fun.
I mean, is it too early to do a podcast? No, it's not too early. We're still in bed. No, it's not too early. I'm just a little quiet today. Like I said, I'm feeling very, maybe, Spellcus, what's the, what's the Yiddish term? Because you didn't sleep.
You're like, you're a little LGD, low grade depression. Yeah, maybe, maybe it is. I don't know. I wouldn't call it that, but maybe it is, but also just very sort of, very kind of, kind of, pensive. Yeah, that's a bad thing. Yeah, that's right. Well, that's all right,
because you know, you know, it's gonna put a nice wash of warms and positivity over your day. Our guest is like, great, I gotta lift the hosts up. Yeah. Here she comes. Our guest is an actor.
So filled with taste talent and accomplishment, I feel classy just thinking about her, you guys. She's got the awards and nominations, sure, a long list of impressive films and a stack of big shot co-stars and directors, but most impressive will is a particular kind of light that she sends out from the character she plays. It's always something authentic.
It's fully human, often complex, but somehow fully relatable. We never catch our acting will. It always just feels like we're spying on a character caught in the middle of something, you know, Sean? How does she do it? What do we personalize as well? Is she enjoying it? Hope we're gonna find out.
What else does she do? Hobbies? Really? Is it like being married to a rock star? Does she prefer coffee? Tea? Cake? Pie? Beyonce or Tate-Tate?
Guys, let's figure it all out. Please welcome Carrie Mulligan. Oh, Carrie. Oh, my God. Oh, my God. Oh, wow. Oh, well, don't you feel warm and washed? I do.
I am a particular fan of Carrie's. Well, a huge fan. It's true. Well, Carrie, it's true. I told you, I was, I've had the pleasure. I've had the, the, the, the, the, yeah, sure. I've seen, I've seen Carrie's latest performance in my show, and I, and it has rocked me since the day I've seen it.
Carrie, I've been telling everybody, I don't want to embarrass you. You're so sweet. It's true. I was so nervous when we, when I, when you were at, hi everyone, by the way, hi. Hi, Carrie. This is a nice to meet you. So nice to meet you.
I was so nervous that you were at Radley's house and we had that screening. And all I wanted to say the whole night was, Marcus and I fall asleep to rest in development, not an unfolding sleeper, but like that's all. You said it. That's very sad. We literally, I can quote the show.
And I was too nervous to say anything and after it's Marcus, I was like, why are you so cool? You should have just said it. And I was like, I got, but I was so excited and so nervous for you to see it. And it meant the world that you liked it. So great. Oh, great.
Love it. Love it. I can't wait to see it. But, but, Kerry, God, it is, Jason, you're right. Kerry, you have done so many, look at how upwell is already. I'm not like, Kerry, you've been listening so far. It's true. It was down, and it was in his tummy. Right, and you just woke him up.
Yeah, I'm in love. Well, you know what it's like with the little ones, right? So, we just sew little Denny woke up at one, and then he bar him up. Yeah, I'm okay. Well, you know what it's like with the little ones, right? Yeah. So, just so little Denny woke up at one, and then he barfed in his bed, and then he came into our bed, then he barfed in our bed, then we stripped all the sheets.
Yeah. It was 115. We're stripping the sheets, and he's on the thing, he's got all those passfiring, and he goes, where are we gonna sleep? Oh!
Oh! Oh, but I know, I've done that. So you've been there. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I know. You can treat them like just like a dog, you know, and put them in a room locked up where you don't appear if he starts crying or yelling or yelling or barking. Yeah. And the throw-up just you can deal with in the morning. Yeah. Yeah. That goes. Where did you sleep, Will? Where did you end up sleeping? Well, we got it was, God, it was a real hodgepodge that all night. I slept on one side of our bed and then Senator took him back to, and was in with his bed.
But one of the good new, one of the good things, and then we'll stop this, we'll get into carries that he learned now, he knows how to throw up in a trap, like in a bucket. Oh, good. He taught him that, and at first he was like, wait, I'm gonna, no, and now he's like, I have to be sick now, and then he goes over and does it.
And it's really sweet that he's learned that. So maybe get a pale, he can just kind of put over his head. You know, like a little little handle. I'm gonna just kind of hang surround his head like a necklace. I'm gonna say your parenting tips are really, they're bordering on dangerous, a lot of them. I'm sorry. I'm gonna get the bad next time.
So Carrie Mulligan, where are we finding you right now? God, it's great to see you. I'm sorry. I'm at the bad next time. So, Carrie Mulligan, where are we finding you right now? God, it's great to see you. I'm in LA. Oh, right. Yeah. Fantastic. Doing the stuff. Oh, yeah, for the press tour, for the movie.
Yeah, so our film comes out very soon. So it worked out that we just suddenly went from 0 to 60 and jumped on flights, and so now we're here. Right, because the strike went away, and you could talk about this thing that I'm sure you and Bradley are excited to discuss because it is so damn good. I mean, I think we've all done projects where it's like, oh, now I gotta go talk about
how great it is in quotes. Yeah, but this one truly is. I know it's so nice to not have to lie. It's so nice to just... Carrie, can I just say, and again, at the risk of embarrassing you, and people will be able to go and can see Maestro in theaters and then be able to watch on Netflix.
I, again, I don't want to embarrass you. I think that your performance in Maestro is one of the great performances I've seen in the last 20 years. I really do agree. I agree. I'm so moving and beautiful. And there's some. Sean, you won't get it.
I won't get it. Sean won't definitely, Sean won't get it because it's not in space. It's just music, piano, and stuff. And there's some. Sean, you won't get it. I won't get it. Sean won't definitely, Sean won't get it, because it's not in space. It's just music or pianos and stuff and it's. No, for him. But, yeah. Buh, buh, buh, buh. Sean, you're gonna, the music part, Sean,
you're gonna, it's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away.
It's gonna blow you away as you think it will blow you away. It's gonna blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you. It's gonna blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you. It's gonna blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as you think it will blow you as done in this film that I, honestly, it's transformative. I hate using the word, because it's so gross, and we all shy away from certain sort of catch phrases that we as actors, or filmmakers, or whatever, often use. I'm not going to say story teller, but you truly are an artist. I really mean that.
It's tight second. It is tight second. I'll follow it only by very closely by in the physically doing pre-hands, but truly. So I just want to say that, whatever you do, if there's ever an endorsement that we've ever done in this show, this is one. Please see Carrie Mulligan in my show. Yeah, yeah. I have a question about it because I didn't get, Bradley showed me, like, clips early on, and he invited me to one screen and I couldn't go, but I can't wait to see it, but when you, I've heard only great things like we're saying, when you do a role like that, how much prep
time do you give yourself? How much work do you put into it before you start day one and how nervous are you in playing such an incredible character on the first day of filming where do you get the confidence like I think I got this are we rolling watch this watch what I'm gonna do with this oh god yeah yeah I don't know I don't I don't I don't I don't think I've had a. I mean, I've had parts, I sort of feel like I've had parts like this on stage, you know, like really, really rich, big kind of sort of something epic about them, parts, but not, like, amazing. I've had such amazing, you know, luck with, with jobs, but on screen, I don't, I'm when he offered it to me, I was shocked, because, first of all, I thought, oh, you think I on screen, I don't, I'm when he offered it to me, I was shocked. Because first of all, I thought,
oh, you think I can act? That's so nice. I think. But secondly, that just, you know, I don't know. It was like, he just saw a star as one. He could have, you know, it was just wild to think, like, oh, gosh, you're trusting me with this. But within that conversation, he said,
you know, if you're gonna do this, you have to go all in, you know, and I thought like, oh, you have to go all in. And I thought, oh God, not all in. You know, but it's not, I've always been a bit like, people keeping their dialect in between scenes and thinking of it. Right. Everyone's got different processes. Yeah. Different definitions of all. Yeah, but then I was like, I think I have to do Bradley's all in, which is, as you will know, like... All in. Yeah, but then I was like, oh, I think I have to do Bradley's all in, which is, as you will know, like.
All in. Yeah, sounds so good when you start. Yeah, and with this one, particularly, he had to be all in, because he not only plays the lead, but also or co-lead, but also wrote it, directed it, produced it. Yeah, that's, it's a lot.
And, Karen, you have to play your character. You, I mean, you and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and go through your life, through this character's life, on this incredible journey, and we see all these different stages, and it's really impressive to watch some, you know, we've, people have done things like that before, but that's no small feat as an actor, to go through that, to track that, to be present in all those different stages of that person's life,
like I imagine is very difficult as an actor. Yeah, I think it was like Bradley did all the work, you know, he did all the work on his character, I mean, I don't know how he did it. He's some sort of like geniuses, just so crazy, you know, like the script, everything is just mad. So he was ringing me up. I'm sure he was doing this to you.
He was ringing me up as Lenny, like two years before we started shooting FaceTiming in character. I mean, it was mad. Oh, wow. You know, I was putting the kids to bed and it would just suddenly be, like, all right, mate, I'm gonna have mate, I'm gonna put later bird signs on the phone But you know, yeah, he's just so I feel like
And so then I got into it really early as well because I signed on in like 2018 and we didn't shoot till 2022 So I had you know time and I had an opportunity to to sort of really kind of Do lots of of what we narrated not put together in Philadelphia, one of his operas. So we did so much that by the time we got onto that, we did this sort of mad dream workshop thing, I'm sure he told you about what we sort of spent a week together crying a lot. And so by the time we got there, it was one of the first, maybe the first time I didn't feel completely terrified on day one, because I sort of felt like, you know, we've kind of got... You know, we've kind of got our thing, and he just...
You know, he made it so that you could just basically do anything, and it didn't matter, and that was so fun. One of the things that I love about your abilities is that you... Every character you play, you're so sort of, it seems in touch with kind of their internal stuff. And you're really doing, you can really feel your character thinking and feeling before they're talking, before they're performing, before they're doing anything physical. That is something that's fairly, That is something that's fairly, it's much easier to capture on film
because camera is close to you, it can be, but on stage, you often have to consider the person in the back row too. Tell me about the difference in process and all of a sudden I don't want to put the audience to sleep, but was that a difficult thing for you to kind of calibrate and modulate as you went from theater into film because you're so small and subtle in film in a great way. Yet I'm sure you can't really do that on stage
and still be as effective. It's weird, because I kind of had to reverse engineering, because my first job was a film, I had done lots I mean I was never going to be like a musical theater was what I wanted to do. Really? Okay. Oh, Sean just woke up. I know. I'm pointing at his little box. Which ones and we'll go through them all. Okay, so we so we so I didn't really kind of so I did Pride and Prejudice. That was my first job and I played this little, you know,
I played one of the Bennett sisters and just ran around, Jenna Malone for the whole summer, like, you know, giggling. And then I went to the Royal Court of Theatre and did my first play straight afterwards and that was like a real, you know, and I didn't train, I didn't go to drama school so I felt completely unqualified to do any of it.
So I sort of, I think I just sort of learned from the job, but I think I only ever found the difference being and reaching the back of the room with my voice, not with my anything else. So I didn't really think I did module anything and maybe that's not, but I've always, but I've also only played like maximum of 1000 seats.
But you definitely had a trust that people were getting it. We're seeing it. You were communicating with the audience. And how did you get that trust, that confidence, that feeling without having gone through any sort of training or any sort of practicing or education in it? What gave you the sense that you were good at acting and that you knew what you were doing
that you were capable of it? I don't know if I got, I mean, I just, I feel like I just got, I got a really great part when I was, when I was 21, I got to play Nina and the Seagull in at the Royal Court in London and, and I worked with an amazing cast on that, and the, and that character's just the, it's the most, it's sort of what I mean about, you know, not getting to play a part like Felicia on screen. You know, that's Nina is sort of that kind of role, you know. She really goes from this innocent young kind of naive, wannabe star to someone who is completely kind of destroyed by her experiences by the end of the breadth of her experience. It's just so amazing.
Yeah. We'll be right back. Smartless. Get support from Sonos. Picture this. Your favorite tunes and movies, but this time, it's like you're right there. How? Thanks to the Sonos, Aura, 300's groundbreaking spatial audio. Aura 300 is a mid-tier, all-in-one plugin, smart speaker designed for immersive sound
and spatial audio listening out loud. When played through compatible devices, spatial audio allows you to feel like the music and sound is all around, you fully immersing you into the content. But here's the real game changer. Using two Aera 300s as Dolby Atmos home theater rears when paired with Ark or Beam.
It's like having your own private cinema right at home. The depth and clarity add a whole new dimension to movie nights. And it's not just about sound. The Aero 300 packs a punch in features too, with Wi-Fi, Bluetooth, and USB-C connectivity. It seamlessly fits into your tech life. Now, I got myself an Air 300 and gang, you know when you're in your house
and you hear a little sound and you look over your shoulder like, who's there? What's going on? Because you're like looking around like, what's going on? How is the sound all around me? I'm freaking out, bros.
I don't know how the tech works, but it's pretty awesome sauce. Head over to sonos.com and enjoy up to 20% of most wanted speakers and sets. Offer valid through December 18th or wall supplies blast. SmartList is sponsored by ADT. Now ADT professionally installs Google Nest products so your home is safe and smart. You can check in on your home and manage your security system from virtually anywhere. With Nest Cams and the Nest Doorbell, you can even get intelligent alerts so you've received notifications on what matters most. Google Nest Cams can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle,
or with the Nest doorbell, even a package. And with Nest aware, as part of your monthly ADT service, you get 30 days of event, video history, and even smarter notifications, like when a familiar or unfamiliar face is seen. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event or verify or cancel on alarm with just a tap.
When the most trusted name in home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries. Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP. Google, Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. Thank you to Macy's for supporting this episode of SmartLess. It's the season of giving and Macy's is making it even more delightful for any of you down to the wire shoppers. They're still time to find the perfect gift at Macy's last minute gift sale. Now until Saturday, December 23rd get an extra 20% off great gifts, including the latest wardrobe updates,
makeup and skincare sets, the season's hottest toys and everything else on their wish list. With such a wide array of options, you'll find something for everyone, including a little something for yourself. So hurry, slay the gift game with Macy's last minute gift sale. The countdown to joy is on. Check out Macy's.com and use promo code gift to save today. One more time. That is code gift at macy's.com. Some exclusions apply. See macy's.com for details. All right, back to the show. But what, what, I like this equation. I was like, what gave you the guts to do this?
I was, I was trying to get to the place of life. No, she's too humble to say, but that it's natural for you. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I know I'm joking because yeah, that's right. It is natural for you. And kind of like Sean, No, no, I was going to say Jason, you touched on it, but in reference to what you had said, Kerry, that you said that you didn't go to drama school or anything.
And yet you lived or you worked in this environment that very much there is a sort of hierarchy in that way because in this sort of the English acting and performing community, if you didn't go to Rada or if you didn't go whatever, there's like kind of like, hmm, who are you a little bit? And you must have felt, and tell me, I'm asking you, did you ever feel like an outsider in that way?
And that you had to work extra hard to prove that you were just as good as a lot of these sort of fops who came out of people who came out of drama school? Oh, yeah. I mean, mean, the first play I did professionally was Straight Off the Pride and Prejudice. And the director had to, so the first preview, they were all, all the cast went into this room to go and warm up. And I could hear it, because they had the little speaker thing
on it, I could hear it, and my dressing room, and they were all like, oh, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, you know, doing all the weird, like, I thought, fuck in hell, like, I'm not. I'm in my whole body just like, closed, I just thought, I'm not doing that, not doing that. And the director, Katie Mitchell, literally came into the room and she physically moved me
into that room and sort of just sat me on the floor and was like, just try. And I just sat there going, oh, God, this is so fucking embarrassing, I can't. No, no, no, no, no, no. But I think maybe towards the end of that, I started feeling a bit more comfortable. It's just sort of felt like, not just embarrassing,
but also like, I look like such a tit. I don't know what I'm, you know, any noises that I make and not the noises you're meant to make, or, you know, but it was funny because that's what I'm saying. Right, we're going to look at you and go like, what noises are you? Yeah, that's correct. We're making these ridiculous.
Yeah, and they were like, but they were like, right, right. I could fire doing Shakespeare monologues and I, you know, it was just sort of, but somehow by the time I got to New York, we did the Seagull in London and we did the Seagull in New York. And in New York, Zoe Kazan played Masha, and we became best friends in the world. And we used to go down stage on every night, and we would just sing, do you hear the people sing from Layma Zoroahblit on stage?
And that was our warm up. Yeah. So you're... That was your honor. That's good that you have at least. That became the thing that, you know, that... So that I made my own weird noise, but, yeah, so I think by the time I did that, I felt like, oh, I kind of, not that I'm like, but I felt
comfortable that I would relax a bit. And did you feel part of the club? Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry,
sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, you kind of feel like, okay, I've now carved out my own sort of path, and I don't have to worry about that other sort of stuff again.
I don't have my own sound. So, so, I mean, yeah, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, so, I think I just, yeah, I all felt kind of fluky for a while, and but I still didn't feel, I mean, definitely went in face, or I felt like completely, I loved just doing all the prep and all that, and feeling like completely immersed in the whole thing film, I always felt like, hello, you know, just,
I'm sorry, sorry, don't mean to just... Just passing through. Like, you stand in front of the camera and sort of... What about, but an education, right? That was, was that that kind of the first thing that really kind of pushed you out into? I mean, it was an Academy Award nomination, right? Did it, was the, was the change in climate?
Was it, was it palpable for you? Was it, was that an exciting thing or a nerve-wracking thing? Because a bunch of really cool stuff followed that. No, yeah, that was totally, I mean, that was, that was a five-week shoot or something. And I thought maybe it would be on in a couple of really cool stuff followed that. No, yeah, that was totally. I mean, that was a five-week shoot or something, and I thought maybe it would be on in a couple of cinemas, and I had no expectations for that at all, and then we went to Sundance,
and it kind of turned into this thing. So, yeah, it was a big shift. And I think, I regret not having as much fun as I should have done. I think I took it all quite seriously, and was quite, and had a real imposter syndrome. You know, I'd be in Rome just thinking, like, what the actual crime do I do?
Well, is that, did that come from a sense of, oh my God, what I always hoped would happen is, it seems like it's about to start, or was it, I had no plans whatsoever, this was kind of fun, and now this has happened, and now I'm expected to kind of make a career of this, and be some big fancy actor. No, I think I definitely was all I wanted to do,
but I think that was, in my mind, I was thinking, okay, good, right, I can get another job. You know, it was that, it was like, this is great, because then, you know, the good part is that the directors are gonna see this, you know? And I'll bet you still feel like that, right? Oh, God, off, yeah. Off this, this, this profession, there's just no guarantees.
Yeah. No idea whether you're gonna be working 12 months or so. Well, I was gonna, yeah, I was gonna ask that, Carrie, like, now with all of the incredible work that you've done, isn't there some sense of like, okay, I think I can, I think I'll be working, or does that never go away? I don't know. I just think, I think you always sort of,, okay, I think I can, I think I'll be working, or does that never go away? I don't know. I just think, I think you always sort of, you know, you're always hoping that that one person sees it and then wants to hire you. Do you know what I mean? Like, you always feel
or that it's to someone's taste. I don't think it ever does go away. Do you watch your stuff? Do you watch your... Do you know the only thing I've watched is my story? It's funny, because I don't really. Really? No, no, no. I've never seen, like, she said that came out last year. I saw promising young woman once. Yeah, you should check it out. Is it because you get self-conscious? Like, do you watch playback on set? No, no, no, no, no. No.
No, it fucks me up completely. No, I can't. I can't look at anything and I can't look at stills. I can't look at... Although, but Bradley was so like... You know, he wanted us to sort of have a sense of what we were making all the time. So I did, I watched that with him and I've watched a couple cuts of, I haven't seen the final, final cut of my story yet. But I will, and I want to, but with most things now, I just... The progression of it is amazing. I mean, it was the first cut I saw was already incredible, but the way he shaped it kept moving it, it never went backwards. It was always, and he's just, he's a great filmmaker.
Yeah, he is. I feel very privileged that you never watched anything and then I got to watch my show with you then. Yeah, yeah. And my husband watched it as well. And he, he's watched it now twice and he's done. He doesn't like the sad parts. He can't watch the sad parts.
Yeah, of course. It must be. Yeah, it was so fun meeting you guys and meeting Marcus. Obviously tell us a little bit. I mean, you're married to, like Jason said, you're married to a rock star. I was like, it's so funny. Marcus Muffered and Sons.
Yeah, Muffered. I did it at the rock star thing, always sounds like, well, you're married to a rock star. I was like, it's so funny. Marcus Mufferd and Sons. Yeah, I did the rock star thing always sounds so. I'm like, well, it's true. Yeah, it is. Well, you know, you must have, did you meet him Jason when you were doing the video? You did the video. I don't think we met that day, but I met you guys at Austin City Limits.
Oh, yeah. At one point, I was there for a radio head show, I want to say. And that was really, really cool. Yeah, we had a blast, too. And that was a, we did a video. You know, Sam Jones directed that. Sam Jones directed the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, it was me, and it was Ed Helms. Ed Helms, yeah. And they've played the band.
They were the band. And in a very campy sort of, we're doing some, like we were the band shooting a video out and some barn and we were playing our instruments. Bound to. Just like, yeah, playing a bunch of grab ass. Yeah, it was some ridiculous and hilarious. Yeah, I love it. I love it. When Jay goes into that voice, you know, because it was amazing. That was that was the comedic, just was that we're, you know, just
just a bunch of Hicks playing, playing guitar and having a good time. Yeah. Do you, were you, Carrie, were you as interested in music before you met him? Or were you, like, or was it, did it heightened after you met? We were like, oh, play the guitar in front of me. I want to know how it works. Like, or did you not prepare that early? On your guitar in front of you. I always loved, I mean, you know, I wanted to do musical theater.
I loved musicals and all those sorts of things. It was not a growing up. Are you saying? I can, I'm like a choir, I can choir sing, you know, wanted to do musical theater. I loved musicals and all those sort of things was not growing up. Are you saying? I can, I'm like a choir, I can choir sing, you know, I can sing enough to hold a tune, but not good enough to do musical theater. So that's why I kind of swerved into just straight acting. But I didn't, I remember seeing Marx's band. Well, we were friends and we were kids, so we went to camp together.
Oh wow. Wait, wait, wait, wait, you guys were playing the house, right? Yeah. Wait, what? Yeah. I know. So we went to camp together. Oh wow wait wait wait wait wait wait you guys were Pen-pals right yeah wait what yeah your pen pals we went to camp together we met when He was ten. I was twelve. Yeah, yeah, we met when we were kids and we guys hook up then We didn't but I do I'd wrote in my diary that he was The nicest the kindest person I'd ever met and I gave him 9.5 out of 10. Wow! What a score! I know! But I said, all score, what score would you give him today? He's getting out there, I'd give him a solid six, but he's the...
Yeah, and I also wrote in my diary that he definitely wasn't boyfriend material. I mean, not that I'd ever had a boyfriend at that time, but I decided that he was not it. That's so crazy that you knew each other. That's crazy. And I am worried. And you stayed pen pals for a while? Well, pen pals were a couple years and we lost touch. Then the internet happened and
we got the internet happened. And we started, we were both on Facebook for like six months, then we both left, so we touched base there briefly. And then we met again, yeah, when I was like 24. And at that point, you guys were like, this is, I mean, we keep running into each other. We are destined to be together. We're probably, we should get married, yeah. Wow.
Did you guys ever have any conversations about how crazy is it that we both ended up doing public jobs and finding a really incredible level of success? Well, what's weird is that we also, not long after we met again as adults, we both worked on the Coen Brothers movie inside Lewand Davis and both independently were hired. Oh, hello, Rumi. Sorry, someone's just come in, J This is the high. Should we hold? Hi. Is it a roommate? Just say hi.
Hi, I can't hear you. Oh my god. Hi guys. Hey really? Hi. Listen, we live together. We have yesterday's guest sitting right next to today's guest. No, I'm a how are you feeling?
I'm getting better. Are you? Very, very sweet to let me be so close to her when she doesn't. The week we are across the whole from each other. Oh, that's a terrible. Did you get the chicken noodle soup? I got the chicken noodle soup, Sean. I didn't know how to reach out to you.
Oh, you're half due. This is the best. I have to show you a picture of it as it came up for the room. One second. Sorry, I'm not. I'm going away. She was sitting, selling center over some chicken noodle soup. I knew you would. When you said that you were going to, I knew going away. She was sick, so I sent her over some chicken noodle soup. I knew you would.
When you said that you were going to, I knew you would. You didn't say that. This is how it arrives. Oh God. It was like a ball of sec. It does look like a ball of sec. That's what it looks like. It looks like it was somebody barf. Oh no, it's short of like this. What's the other note? All that is sweet.
It looks like a ball of sec. Yeah, it does look like a ball of sec. That's what it looks like. It was somebody barfed in a ball. I'm glad you didn't put our names on it, Sean. Where was it from, Sean? They're saying it looks like he barfed in a ball. It's like I barfed in a ball.
I loved it. Thank you, Sean. Sean, was it just from Room Service? Yeah, I think so. I check your bill, because he might have just put it on your bill. All right. I think so. Yeah. Check your bill because he might have just put it on your bill. Okay, bye guys. Bye bye.
I'll be back in 20 minutes. Okay, I'll see you guys in a minute. Bye bye bye bye. That's a pretty money. She's not in for me now. She's just talked her two days ago. I know. I was like, I'm nervous.
You're not nervous anymore. No, I'm fine now. You know what? I wanted to know because we haven't done this part of the, of the, of the, of the, of the, I know, I know. I was like, I'm nervous. So you're not never getting more. No, I'm fine now. You know what? I wanted to know, because we haven't done this part of the interview process yet.
How did we talked about you doing, you know, Pride and Prejudice and doing all these things. But what was the thing that, how did you start? What was your thing where you went like, oh, this is what I want to do? Do you know, it's so funny. I said this to Kevin Bacon the other night. I was in, I was at this like, oh, this is what I want to do. You know, it's so funny. I said this to Kevin Bacon the other night. I was in, I was at this like,
taste makery, you know? Yeah, sure. In New York for my sister, and he came with his lovely wife, and they came over to say, in that they liked the film, and I said, you know, you're literally, it was seeing you do this one man show in New York, but it was the trip that I, so I was about 14, I went to New York with my mum
to go and see me saw Cabaret and we saw Playbit. He was in where it was a one-man show, and it was at the Walter Kerr Theatre, and I watched it, and I thought, that's it, that's like, this is like a magic trick, you know, that he's doing this play for, however, long 90 minutes, or on just completely on his own. And that cabaret, well, that trip, that was when I thought, right, this is the thing. And I got to tell him, which is so cool. And then when I went back to New York and did the Seagull, when I was about 22, it was at the Walter Curve. Yeah. And there's this amazing line in the Seagull, when Nina, in the second act, she's talking to this writer, that she's a budding actress, and she meets this famous writer, it was played by Tuotá Legifor and London and Peter
Sarsgard and New York. And there's this, you know, they have this conversation, and she's just sort of completely overroared by what a genius he is and how he creates. And at the end of the, and she falls in love with them, and at the end of the scene, he walks off stage, and she's on her own, and she sort of looks out over the lake, which is the audience, and she says, I'm dreaming. And I could never do it in London. For some reason, I just couldn't.
I just always felt like such a knob, and I was just going, I'm dreaming, and then just walk off stage. And the director was always like, come on. And it was the first night of the Walter Kerr, and I looked out and I thought of this sort of 14-year-old me sitting in the stalls, and I said it, and it was the first time I sort of really said it.
You know, it was just, it was just, that's cool. Yeah, it was cool. I love it. Literally just giving goosebumps. Yeah, yeah. Was it, what was the, again, in my crappy research, I stumbled upon something and I can't find it now, but was, what was the show that, where the curtain came down and tell me this is a good theater story? This is my, I was going to say, sure, and this is my good theater story.
I did this one woman show called Girls and Boys in 2018 and I did it at London the Royal Court and then I transferred it to this little theater in New York. And in the show, I played this mother, this woman, and at the start of the show, I'm in front of this curtain, and I am, is a monologue. And then the curtain comes up in a blackout, and I suddenly, there's urine like someone's kitchen living room, and I had these scenes with these invisible children. And the play's very funny and then incredibly dark,
and it's about 90 minutes, where it just, there's blackouts in between scenes, and I just go back and forth and run this curtain. And in New York, there's something, it was the first preview and we got about, it was sort of about 20 minutes for the end of the play and it had gotten to the sort of quite serious part and I did the scene with the kids and then when the blackout was going forward to stand in front of the curtain. And by curtain, you know, we mean like a wooden metal kind of thing that comes down. And something went wrong with the mist timing of the curtain
and as I kind of came underneath it, it landed sort of on my head. On your head, the whole curtain. Like a pipe. Yeah, well, just sort of struck me and then I shoved away from it and it carried on going down, you know, because it just... Oh, God, because that thing doesn't light. That thing weighs a ton. Yeah, well, it just sort of struck me, and then I shoved away from it, and it carried on going down, you know, because it just took a long time. Because that thing doesn't light, that thing weighs a ton. No, no, no, no.
I mean, it's like a sort of wooden structure thing, and it comes down quickly, because it was a quick, kind of change into the next scene. So my hair was kind of fucked up, and I sort of, it was unbelievably painful, but then the lights came up, and no one had seen it. So I, so it's not like someone had seen an accident before I could go like, oh, that hurts.. So I just carried on and did that rest and with my hair, and I'm like,
what? And then I, and then I got to the end of it and, you know, finished the play and walked off stage and just burst into tears, and I was hysterical, and I was also convinced that I was going to die, because I thought, you know, head injuries, concussion, blah, I went back up to my room, and I was, you know, it was this tiny, tiny theatre. It didn't have a proper dressing room. It just had like a curtain, sort of one of those partitions and a bit of a curtain. And I was sobbing on the floor and, you know,
various people are trying to calm me down. I was going, oh really? I think it's really bad. And then someone from the theatre comes in and says, I'm so sorry. Um, Bradley Cooper's just sitting just outside. And Bradley was, I had come to the first preview, and was sitting on the sofa outside just waiting.
And this was how many years ago? This was 2018, so this was, yeah. And so, and then I said, oh, bring him in. And he, and he, and he, and he came in and he just got down on the floor and like, looked in my eyes, looked at my pupils, and was like, right, we're going to hospital. So we went and I was like, oh, you did?
And he took you to the hospital? Yeah, I took me to the hospital. See? The first time you met Bradley, he took you to the hospital. No, no, no, we're going to hospital. So we went and I was like, oh, you did it? And he took it to the hospital? Yeah, I took it to the hospital. The first time you met Bradley, he took it to the hospital. No, no, no, no, we had met a bunch of times before. We had come to see me when I did a play with Bill Nye because he's good friends of Bill and we have the same publicist. We'd like bumped into each other at stuff. But yeah, he was good.
By the way, he's really good at taking people to the hospital. This is right here. I know, I thought I was bad. He just took, he just took Brooke, you know, to the hospital last week. But I want to say, I don't know about you guys. Kerry, I love when you talk and you're describing anything, you make anything, you can, you can describe anything to me. I just want to call you, can we be friends so that you can just describe? I just want you to describe stuff to me.
Have you just said, Matt? No, we met at Bradford's camp. Yeah, we're Bradford's camp. I just love listening to you tell stories. I could just listen to you talk about like you do. Can I just quickly tell you, because I said at the beginning that I, what a massive fan I was of both of you in a rest of development, but Sean.
Uh-oh. Not so much. That's what I was going to say. Sorry, was that not what you were going to say? That's exactly what I was going to say. No, big, big time fan. And when I went to Chile to meet the family... The restaurant? He goes, you got a Chili's once I went to the restaurant. So you didn't do it. I went to the Chile, the country, to go meet the family of the woman I play in my strip in Santiago. And I went there before we started shooting
what was meant to be a three-day trip and I got COVID on my way out so I was stuck there so I had to stay another week and a half and my kids were in New York with my mum and it was and I was I mean really really horribly horribly upset So I literally couldn't leave my room so I was was in my room in Chile for, and I watched, for the maybe 50th time, Will and Grace, from the first episode of the first season, all the way to the end. No, that was true.
And that was what I, yeah, and that was my hat. That's very sweet, Carrie, thank you. That's amazing. I'm guys, what was your favorite episode? Sorry, tell, okay, what is this Will and Grace? Is that a play? Yes, it is. It was a film, Will and Joan. It was one woman show, yeah. One man, tell it. Okay, what is this Will and Grace? Is that a play? Yes, there is. It was a film.
It was one woman show. Oh. One man, one woman. Yeah. I love. That's sweet, honey. Thank you so much. No, really, I love it so much.
I think it's incredible. It really is. It's chasing. No, I'm serious. I was a big dork fan of yours before I met you. But Jason, you came to like, two or three shows too. Yeah. Then you came to the last, the very, very last show.
Oh. You went to the last one. Yeah, Jay was at the very last show. We'll be right back. Smartless fans, listen up. Have you heard you can listen to episodes of this very show, Add Free, and One Week Early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership? That's right.
All your favorite smartness episodes can be heard on Amazon Music ad-free and you'll always be the first one to catch our new episode so you can brag to your friends. Now listen, some people might be bragging, some people might be criticizing. They might say, oh boy, listen, I heard the latest smartness because I got this ad-free Amazon Music and you'd save yourself the problem.
You don't need to listen. So see you can either be ahead with positive or negative. The choice is yours. That's all we're trying to do is load you up with choice, you know, but that's not all. You can listen to your other favorite shows, like I don't know, bad dates
and just Jack and Will, early and ad free too. They also have favorites like the daily part might take and up first all without ads. You know what this means uninterrupted listening so no more cliffhangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad free top podcasts so we know they definitely have something for you and it's already included in your prime membership. To listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com slash smart list. That's Amazon.com slash smart list or download the Amazon music app. It's just that easy. Happy holidays, everyone. And my gift for you? It's the gift of comedy, two comedies, in fact.
The comedies of two amazing Johns. John Lerichette in the new season of Nightcourt, and John Crier in his new comedy extended family. That's right. Court is back in session, Tuesdays on NBC, with America's number one comedy, Nightcourt, starring the iconic John Lerichette in the role that won him so many awards it's embarrassing. And after that, it's another TV legend, John Cryer.
In a comedy about life and family after divorce, extended family, also starring the hilarious, Donald, Faesonzon and Abigail Spencer. It's the gift of comedy people to comedies starring two Johns, John Lericette and John Cryer, Nightcourt, and extended family. Two gifts you will surely love this season, unless you are a miserable Scrooge person. Tuesdays on NBC starting January 2nd. starting January 2nd. Thank you to Audible for their support. A deep and sincere thanks. Because Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app.
You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. There's an incredible selection of audio books across every genre from best sellers, new releases, celebrity memoirs, mysteries, thrillers, motivation, wellness, business, more. As an audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog of thousands of titles. Now, I just recently took a look at Liz Cheney's, I believe it's called, Oath in Honor. I mean, I'm a political junkie. I like to hear about it from all sides. So she's got a bunch of really interesting stuff
in her book about all of the Misha Goss and it's compelling. It's whatever the digital equivalent of a page turner is, it's that. I mean, it's clickable, maybe something? I don't know. We'll get back to that. I mean, it's clickable. Maybe something. I don't know. We'll get back to that. But new members can try audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless.
And now back to the show. Now I'm imagining, Carrie, that with your, you're, you're, you have a very exciting life with all the fancy places you get to go for your work, but all the fancy places you get to go for Marcus' work too. What is the, have you, did you meet the most impressive person in your work or when you were with him for his work? Like, who got you most starcer? Cause like actors always geek out around musicians
and vice versa for athletes. Who's been the coolest person you've met with Marcus? Springsteen was the coolest. Yeah, that's good. By a long way. I mean, not by a long way, I've met lovely people. But Springsteen made me go, I just, and I don't think I could,
I couldn't really function. I just sort of, you know, he just ruins me. Yeah, but going back to like the thing I asked you before, were you a fan of Marcus's music or that style or that genre, or did he open you up to be like, like, what did you listen to before and what was it the same then and now? No, I was like S-club seven, Backstreet Boys, West Life. Yeah. There was a brand of music that they used to call, I went to boarding Club 7, Backstreet Boys, West Life. There was a brand of music that they used to call,
I went to boarding school and I used to, the girls at school used to, my genre was Carrie Trash, because I just listened to like... Carrie Trash. Yeah, Carrie Trash. Wait, Backstreet Boys, was that Justin Timberlake or was that in sync?
That was in sync. That was very good. Backstreet Boys was, yeah, sort of... But when you worked, didn't you work with Justin and... In Inside Leon Davis, yeah. Where I worked with Marcus, and that was the thing it was, yeah, sort of. But when you worked, didn't you work with Justin and, uh, Luenal? In Inside Lu and Davis, yeah. Where I worked with Marcus, and that was the thing I was going to say that if we had not met as adults in Nashville, which is how we did end up meeting, we would have met on that job because we both got hired, uh-huh, independent of one another to do it. Because he did the music and I did the acting thing.
Got you. So you didn't really listen to Mumford and Sons before you? Wow. No, but I thought, so I went to a Laura Marling gig when I was like 19, a sort of, you know, church in London and Mumford and Sons with a support act. There was one of their first ever gigs and I, and when he came out, I remember thinking, oh, God, I knew a guy called Mumford. I went to campus, you know, but he was so tall and when I met him, he was tiny and then he started singing
and I said to my best friend, Moth, next to me, I went, oh God, Moth is so shouty. Because it was very shouty back then and I think he's less shouty. Oh my God. It was very shouty. I don't know how funny. I like it, you're like, in my defense, it was very shouty.
Kerry, be honest, how many ace of Base concerts have you been to? I never watched the concert, but I would have died too. Okay, I would have gone with you. Yeah. Yeah. What can you tell us about, because you know, I would imagine you've had some, some pretty low hanging fruit thrown your way because you're so successful like, hey, why don't you be the star of this crappy film or let's give you all the money to do this.
You always pick these incredibly tasteful projects, whether it be the premise of it or the people that are involved with it. Tell us a little bit about what's the most attractive thing about a project for you. Is it the characters, is it the script, is it the director, is it the, how do you go about picking all these great things and never picking any stinkers? Looks like a lot of discipline. I've been really lucky. I think I also, yeah, I think largely big time
director definitely, but within that just, well, you know, my agent tour, who's been my agent for almost 20 years, she's like wonderful, and she sort of family. And when an education happens and suddenly I was getting off for jobs a bit more, you know, she said, look, you're in this really rare part of an actor's career where you can, you don't have to say yes to everything. And that's a real privilege. And whilst you're in that place, you really shouldn't take a part unless you can't bear the idea of someone else playing it. And you've got this capital and it's yours. Yeah. And if you can imagine someone else, one of you can tell her is playing the part and thinking like, well, that's okay. You know, going to sit in the cinema with someone else
and being all right with it, then she was like, then don't do it. Wow. But do you, when you look at, when you look at stuff, do you think like, oh, this is gonna work? Or do you think, no, I have to do this because it really speaks to me
and this is something where I can really, I feel like I can, there's something about it that I feel like I can, there's something about it that I feel like I can express myself in a really way or whatever, or do you think about the success of it? Like, oh, this will be a cool thing and people will think this is cool. Oh God, no, no, no.
No, I mean, I generally have a bit of a kind of, if it doesn't scare me, it's not enormously attractive, which is, you know, the kind of masochistic. I mean, girls and boys, when I did that, the monologue, I couldn't get through the first page of a dress rehearsal until the first preview. I mean, I literally couldn't get on stage. Oh, no. Like, there was something about talking, well, but you know what else it was? It was that the first sort of 45 minutes of the play was funny, and that scared the shit out of me. Like, when I read it, it made me laugh. And the idea of having failed
by not making the audience laugh just felt, I mean, I could get out there and cry for England, but I think comedy is so hard. And the idea of going out and bombing in that way, and people not laughing. And also the play required that. It needed the first half to be funny, because the second half was just devastating. So I couldn't just make it.
It would just be misery porn if it was just, I couldn't do that. And that's misery porn. So I, you must feel more confident about your ability to be comedic inside your skill set and your taste. In other words, like you're not trying to be funny doing broad stuff. You're being successfully funny playing characters that are eccentric or broken or flawed or like promising young woman.
That's a dark comedy that you know, it just seemed you were very confident with your dark comedic sensibility. I think with the theatre thing, it was that like, I just needed to figure out who I was talking to. You know, there was some part of me that thought, what is this, you know, is this a convention for grief or what, you know, I just couldn't figure out who the audience was because I didn't have that other actor on stage with me to tell the, you know, to communicate with, so I was like, the biggest block was like, who are these people that I'm telling
this thing to? And then when I kind of figured that out and you know what else? I took my shoes off. And suddenly when I was barefoot, I could do it. It was the weirdest thing. Really? Really relaxing. Yeah, I just, the whole, I thought it was just grounded and I was like, oh, okay.
So now it makes, and then it became my favorite thing I've ever done on stage, and I absolutely loved it. And I sort of mourned it for a long time. I'm like, this is... I warned you, I warned you blown away, but the first play you did, and then subsequently everything else, weren't you blown away by the endurance that you have to figure out in order to do, especially a one woman show, where it's just you
and the energy that you have to find every single day of your life to do that at that time. It's mad, it's mad. And it just gets impossible with kids because you will do it. So you find yourself barefooting pregnant? Yeah. Well, I was pregnant on Broadway when I did skylight with Bill. And almost seven months pregnant by the time I finished it. And I've never been so.
And it was so funny because the baby would sort of respond to their flaws. I thought this was really setting us up for a problem. But yeah. You know, you speak of what for you now? Now that you've, I mean, you've got three kids, you've got, as Jason said at the start, you've got all this, you know, all the acclaim and in respect that you could, you could ever want doing what we do. What for you is, what does success mean to you now? Like what is, what would you go like at the end of a day or a week or a month, you say, like, yeah, you feel like, great, because you've had all this stuff and you've had all the thing. Like what, what do you look for now? What are the things that are what are the
mountains that you want to climb sort of personally as a person? I don't know. I mean, I feel increasingly just sort of unbelievably lucky. We've got three healthy kids and we both get to do jobs that we really love, you know. And that's so that I think that gives you a lot, you know, that makes... that takes away a lot of kind of regular life stress, you know, so many people have to work and jobs they hate and, you know, and so many people, you know, you just see more and more of your friends and people around you, you know, sort of hearing stories of people's
health issues or kids that have not, you know, and it's just, God, she's think constantly, like, wow, we've managed to really swerve that stuff so far, touch with all that, like, you know, thank you, Lord, but it just feels like that is, you know, happy, you know, healthy home life and also like the ability to work. And, you know, whatever scale that is, whether it's giant films or whether it's theatre or whether it's just, you know, but to be able to work and actually go and earn money doing something that you really, really love,
it doesn't really need to be any kind of trajectory for me. It's just, you know, that hopefully next year, I'll get to make another film at some point that's good with all of us. Thank you, chances are good. Chances are pretty good on that. Yeah, these are the best. Well, how had you worked with it with a director
that was also acting in the scene with you before Lysro? How did you enjoy that or not? And what was Bradley's style with that? Would he direct you during a take? Or would he wait until the end of it and be a director as opposed to giving you direction in character in very soon?
I loved it. I loved it. I loved it. Um, he would do it. Well, he wouldn't do it like, well, he was basically Lenny from the minute he walked on set. So, you know, he was in his, you know, whole thing dialogue, his dialect. He was chain smoking by the camera directing everyone.
Well, just, just such, my sister knows, um, he plays Leonard Bernstein. Bernstein? Bernstein people. Bernstein. Bernstein. Yeah, I can't get any wrong, the Bradley was so annoyed with me. And you play Leonard's wife, yeah. Yeah, I play his wife.
Yeah, I loved it. It was, you know, because he would direct me not through, sort of, giving me verbal directions as in Do This Do That. He would, he would sort of mold the scene or play his role in a way that would affect mine, you know. So it would be more in the way that he would play Lenny that would affect mine, Felicia, then actually sort of, but he also gave me like note notes, but a lot of it was sort of, I'd find us taking it in a certain direction because he had kind of pushed it that way through playing his role the way it was. Did any part of that seem interesting or attractive to you to do one day?
Big no. No. No. No. Really. Tell us, come figure out how we do it. I can't figure out how anyone does it. I think it's, I mean, I don't know how you do it. It's just, yeah, I can't.
But you've been on so many great sets with so many incredible directors. Like, I mean, I just, I don't know if I'd be able to say a word if I was performing for the Cohen brothers, saying that them alone would be, or Steve McQueen, or, I mean, these directors, you could cherry pick from so many great ones and probably do an incredible job as a director if you wanted to. I just don't, yeah, I don't have the heart for it. I think you have to love it so much, because it's such an incredible amount of work. I think you have to love it so much, because it's such an incredible amount of work.
I think you have to absolutely love it to be able to do it. And I just don't have it. I just feel like such a jobbing actor. I just want to be surprised by something. Well, it's not the acting. So why are you here? Why are you here doing press-well?
Yeah, well, we've got you. Yeah. Why are we've got you? What are you going to do? Do you have time to go hang out while you're in LA or do fun things or is it all worth it? Oh, this is a trap. Carry, tell me.
You're busy. So you're busy, you're busy. I'm busy. I'm pretty for lunch. I'm going to go to a private, like an early breakfast tomorrow. No, no, no. No, no, no, no. It's actually, it's quite nice.
Like, today I'm having lunch with, so I'm doing this thing tonight. Can I plug my charity? Yes, please. Oh, yes. All simers or... No, this is a war-kid. War-kid. War-kid. So this is not my... I didn't found this charity, but I'm an ambassador for this charity. So tonight, there's a dinner for a variety dinner
and they're giving people prizes for whatever. So I have to make a speech, but we get $10,000 for Waterchild. And Waterchild UK is a charity that I've worked with for about 10 years that looks after children in conflict zones. So today I'm having lunch with Rob Williams, who's flown in for a He's the CEO of the charity, and he is my absolute hero. And has been, you know, an NGO worker for 30 years and runs this organisation and travels all over the world doing, you know, an NGO worker for 30 years and runs this organization and travels all over
the world doing, you know, amazing work. I mean, recently got back from Afghanistan where he was literally negotiating with the Taliban about women being able to go to work for, for watch out. So, like, that has to be negotiated. It's astonishing. Yeah, it's wild. But they, you know, obviously do incredible work and never more needed than now. That's unbelievable. And there's some unbelievable, there are people out there doing stuff like that. First of all, you're involved with it is amazing. And there are people out there doing important stuff. And obviously everybody's got their own thing.
Sean was saying the other day, he couldn't find parking on Crescent next to the Beverly Hills Hotel. And so we had to end up had to use the valet. But everybody's got their things. That's how, yeah., yeah, they put up their website Sean You can donate to yeah, Sean Hayes You can click on and then carry hang on we'll get to you So but no, but it carry is there is there some sort of a website a website or is it somebody wants to check out what's going on? WWW.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W.W. art therapy and fucking great. It's linked to help them with the covers.
It's really cool. Yeah, it's amazing, amazing work. Yeah. What do you guys do that that dumbs it down after you're finished doing your your incredible smart work? Oh, um, lots of television. Lots of telling. Lots of telling.
Now this is reality television or is it like, you know, I do a bit of reality television, but he is passionate about below deck, which is- Oh, wow. Which I can't go there, but he's that good. I go there, and then I feel like I need a shower afterwards. Who, who deck? Oh, below deck.
Below deck. Oh, below deck. Oh, below deck. Oh, sorry, below deck. Below deck. Sometimes Scott and I play that. Got it. And what is you guys just, you know, change who plays deck?
Yeah, that's it. Yeah. So you'll watch some TV, we will. What's your first TV? Yeah. Are you guys foodies? Do you like restaurants? Do you go over to friends houses?
We do friends houses. We do, we live, you know, we do quite, not mega outdoorsy, but quite outdoorsy. Wait, wouldn't I be like camping? You guys go camping? No, he goes camping with the kiddles. I draw the line at camping. What does the camping look like? Is there a fancy van that they sleep in or they pitch a tent? It does. He's a real man. We're near where you live, we're like a light to dream.
Like outside our house. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of my head. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back. I'll tell you in the back. I'll tell you in the back of that. I'll tell you in the back. I'll tell you in the two. Kerry, we are over time. We owe you five minutes of dollars. That's true. Thanks for saying yes to doing this. Oh my God. That's a having me open. That's so cool. Best of luck with all of the chat and giggle sessions you're going to have for Maestro.
It's incredible. Incredible. And worth your talking about it. It's incredible. There's a scene again, before we let you go, there's a scene when you're folding the tissue paper that for me is just like an absolute, just brought me to my knees. I can't believe it. Yeah, so good.
So everybody go see Meister. And also one more time with the web address for the charity please. Oh, www.wchild.co.uk. They need you right now. Yeah, they need you right now. Sean, the one for the parking spots. So that's just Sean Hayes, the up and down. That's just a hot track.
That's a hot track. Sean, go one really quick with your mobile number. Yeah, so it's 310. OK. Carrie, have a great day. Thank you. Say hi to Marcus. Bye great day. Thank you. Say hi to Marcus.
Bye, carry. Thank you. I'll stick to you for the reshoots. You know, we're going to do some reshoots on this. Yeah. We'll check your bill. All right. We'll see you now.
What's the slammichut? Oh, do I? Yeah. Bye. Jason, what a guest. Yeah. You did it. What a guest you had.
Oh, you did it. You've done good. It's like one of our great, great actors. Oh. I was just like, when I heard that Bradley was going to have her in the film, I just like, it made me, you know what people put certain actors in certain projects? It just elevates. Elevates.
Elevates. Yeah. And it makes it, it says to the audience, okay, this is what the film is and this is what film isn't. It's real, right? It just kind of gives it this wash, this patina of like, oh, we're in good hands here. She, that, when it gets pissed. Well, well, you gotta,
a movie that you're gonna be doing with Bradley, when you were telling me about going through some casting and it really doesn't make it. Yeah, it's exciting, it's exciting. And she carries one of those people who does, like you say, kind of raises it and then over delivers. I should have say over delivers, because it sounds negative, but she's so. She comes to my house and delivers stuff.
She always brings extra stuff. She brings too much. She overdresses. Yeah, it's like super. How about the Chee and Marcus met. They were pin pals. Yeah, that's wild. Like they met by Cam.
Friends and camp. They were friends and camp. Pin pals. I mean, that pals. Yeah, that's wild. And like, they met for a camp. They were friends in camp, pin pals. I mean, that's, yeah. I wrote a couple good jokes. These were, he's working on a lot. Go ahead, no, Sean's got a couple good ones from the other day, please.
Hey, do you know what happened to the cow that was lifted into the air by a tornado? No. It was an utter disaster. Sean, what was the one? I have a belt. Oh, Jay, I have a belt. Will you killed me the other day about the cataracts? Oh, my God.
I said, it's not my joke. I heard that somewhere. Well, you can't say it here, but it's a funny one. Sean, my other one was I have a belt, I have a belt made out of a hundred dollar bills. It's a waste of money. I heard a couple of little chuckles. Boy, if you could do one right now, the third one, and that there's a buy in it, that would be really impressive. Okay. All right. So what did the dad Buffalo say to the kid Buffalo on his first day of school? I don't know. Bye, son!
Bye! Bye! Bye! That's pretty great. And smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Bloss. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barberco. If you like Smartless, you can listen early and add free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen to add free on Amazon music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com-slave-survey. Hi, it's me, the Grand Poova of Bahambad, the OG Green Grump, the Grinch. From Wandery! Tis the Grinch Holiday talk show is a pathetic attempt by the people of O'Vill to use my situation
as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch, along with Cindy Luhu. Hello everyone. And of course my dog Max. Every week for this complete waste of time. Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire.
They'll try to get my heart to grow a few sizes, but it's not gonna work, honey. Your family will love the show. As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show early
and add free right now by joining Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tins the Grinch Holiday talk show early and add free right now by joining Wondery Plus. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.